this is a production of cornell
university
okay so um again thank you so much for
the invite for for myself in virginia
and i'm going to start
our discussion here and turn it over to
virginia in a few minutes so we're going
to talk about genetics transgenics and
speed breeding to restore
the american chestnut
and this first slide here i think kind
of encompasses quite a bit of what we do
here in the left photo you see
a chestnut seedling that's one of our
our transgenic
crosses that's got an extra gene for
blight tolerance we'll explain how we do
that in a few minutes and so in our
greenhouse then we're producing pollen
male pollen for use to take it to the
field here on the right side of your
screen you see one of our four big wild
type chestnut trees
in maine this is a tree about 40 years
old maybe 50 feet tall that we've used
uh over the past couple years for
crossing with our transgenic pollen and
you can see a characteristic form of
this tree that indicates it's suffering
from the
uh accidentally imported fungal blight
you see this big cluster of of branches
and leaves here on the bottom indicating
there's fungal blight up
above in the stem and in the branches
and it's it's trying to compensate and
grow uh below the fungal blight um so
that's sort of
telltale sign of what what the problem
is
out in the field
okay so um so we're going to talk today
about the progress we've made at the
university of new england une but i want
to acknowledge our colleagues our
scientific collaborators at uh down down
the road from you at in syracuse at the
environmental science and forestry
college the three individuals here in
this picture on the right
uh bill powell who's the person has
actually inserted the uh the wheat chain
into the chestnut that
gives it light tolerance alice and oaks
that's interesting so she did her phd on
chestnuts but she's now working on
uh the elm tree and restoring the elm
tree based on the
uh the work she did with with chestnuts
in working on yellow
elm yellows and then andy newhouse also
super important to the project and one
of our major collaborators
so we're going to talk about our
restoration science today but we find
sometimes humanists can tell the stories
so much more
powerfully
um than we can so i'm going to turn over
just to a real quick two-minute video
produced by a documentary
a videographer here at une who has
really uh latched down to our story
and is excited about it and put together
this little video that i'm going to
share with you right now that kind of
gives you an overview of what we're up
to
okay so to remember this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're here doing a major ecological
restoration project where we're making
some great strides today
in the direction of bringing back the
american chestnut tree to the eastern
united states
so what we're doing is
go up in the lift you can find the
female flowers called the birds and we
prepare them by clipping off the male
captains
and
put a protective bag around them so
there is no open cross-pollination from
other chestnuts in the area
we pollinated the first
main wild chestnut trees ever that were
pollinated with
with pollen that we created in our in
our greenhouse in our lab that has light
tolerance so this pollen has an extra
gene that allows it to withstand the
this invasive fungal blight that has
wiped out the entire virtually the
entire population of the american
chestnut tree throughout its eastern
range from maine to alabama and across
to indiana
we collected the fertile nuts we tested
them to see if they've inherited the
gene for flight tolerance
close to above 47 and a half percent of
them did which is what what you'd expect
because of the genomics and now we are
beginning to grow those out in our
greenhouse
and we've also exchanged our chestnut
seeds that have supply tolerance with
our partners throughout the eastern
united states
with partners like university of new
england we're able to broaden
everybody's horizons by working both
inner chapter and having the expertise
of the university
so here in cape elizabeth
we have the first field experiment ever
in new england where we are planting the
american chestnut trees that have an
extra gene for blight tolerance
so we know from lab experience that the
extra gene protects the tree from the
fungal blight now we need to see how it
performs in more natural conditions and
this is the first time this has been
attempted in new england and so our cape
elizabeth site is very important for the
future of the american chestnut treaty
okay trying to get out of this
screen
let's see if i go over here okay
um
okay so we're back to the powerpoint on
your end i want to make sure
okay
okay so
so hopefully that gives you a bit of a
flavor for what our project's about
and um so here you see the native range
of the american chestnut up till about
1900 when the fungal blight began to um
cut away at the population of which
reached close to four billion trees uh
and it's at its peak and this uh this
this fungus is crafinetria parasitica
which has asian origin and was
accidentally imported with the asian
species
in the late 1800s
so cryphenetria parasitica what does it
do to the american chestnut tree well it
finds fissures in the bark weaknesses in
the in the chestnut bark and penetrates
to reach the living layers
on
saplings
you can see it's
can be quite aggressive this orange
indicates the fungal blight surrounding
the
uh the stem and killing the tree
above the stem
it does not the fungal blight does not
kill the chestnut tree below the ground
the microbes protect it and so what you
see happen then is that you see these
root chutes coming up
uh and from the root root side of the
tree
uh
and so
so you have sort of a functionally
extinct species that's that's still
present often on the forest floor but
does not reproduce does not play its
psychological role and then on the right
you see what the
fungal blight looks like
microscopically
it spreads both through the air and
through
squirrels and birds um so and it's
ubiquitous so it's not going to go away
so the solution is not to
eliminate the the imported fungal blight
but to try to deal with it
and try to reduce its uh toxicity
so so much work
has been done and i'm going to just say
a few words about a more traditional
approach more breeding approach to
trying to deal with the fungal blight
and that's involving breed co-breeding
or crossing the chinese
chestnut which is castaneda melissama
with the american chestnut which is
castaneda dentata and you see from
historical genomic analysis that the two
species have been separated for about 20
million years
uh in the and the melissa ma the chinese
co-evolve with the fungal blight so it
tolerates the blight it it the blight
reproduces on the melisma but it doesn't
kill it so it functions as a separate
trove in the context of the united
states where the
the chestnut here this
native species
has no experience prior to this
accidental importation the fungal blight
acts as a necrotroph so it kills the
american chestnut tree but it doesn't
need to it can function quite fine as it
does in asia for millions of years as a
as a saprotroph
okay so then the idea has been in the
breeding program to
uh
to take the
the important genes for blight tolerance
from the chinese tree you can see it
depicted here on the right it's a it's a
low kind of spreading tree more of an
orchard shaped tree the american
chestnut is a tall canopy tree that
reaches over 100 feet tall
so you see they're very different
phenotypically
so that the approach has been to try to
bring over what's what's good about the
chinese genome but retain the
phenotypic form of the american chestnut
and that produces what we call an f1 a
50 hybrid
uh so they do they do
interbreed there is some sterility but
but despite the millions of years of
separation they can reproduce but you
you produce something that's not
competitive in the forest because of its
size and of course it has
way more genes at this stage than you'd
want to restore a native species to the
eastern u.s forest
so what has been going on in breeding
then is to select
generation after generation of these
crosses that phenotypically look like
they have
a substantial amount of blight tolerance
and
prior to the current genomic revolution
that we're fortunately part of today and
we're learning so much from the thinking
based on these generations of breeding
was that it was only two or three
chinese chestnut genes that mattered
that needed to be moved over so it
looked like a fairly doable
uh breeding project
and then eventually the idea after six
generations and this takes decades to do
in the field the idea would be that
you'd have a
a tree that had high levels of light
resistance or tolerance
which was hoped but that has not uh
turned out to be the case why
well again because of genomics we can
look now at the
the genomic profile of the ch the
chestnut tree the chestnut tree has has
12 chromosomes
and um look at well where are the parts
of these chromosomes that really matter
that
significant loci for blight tolerance
and these are it won't go into a lot of
detail on this but there's two different
major lines of chinese trees that have
been used in that breeding program the
clapper line in the graves line
and you can see wherever you see the
line that
bumps up
it's correlated with phenotypic results
that indicate relative light tolerance
and so you see that the basic point is
that the blight tolerance is scattered
across at least nine of the
chromosomes you see that the two lines
are correlated but not perfectly so
there are different things coming over
from each of those lines and so the
major challenge of this breeding
approach is how would you bring over the
important loci and how many do you need
to
bring over this is work that other
scientists are working on uh but you can
see it's a tremendous challenge
what we're doing is a different approach
um in in that
there is um
a common defense amongst plants to
fungal attack not only the cryptonetria
parasitica that attacks the chestnut but
other types of fungus and that's to uh
utilize an enzyme naturally occurring
enzyme called oxalate oxidase or what we
abbreviate
as oxo and this is widespread amongst
plants um
and here's an example of a variety of
different wild plants that have the oxo
enzyme
and a whole bunch of domesticated plants
that also have the enzyme so it's likely
that you in the last few days consumed
this enzyme you know if you've eaten
barley or banana or strawberries or rice
or or wheat wheat is the one that uh
that our work
uh features um mainly because wheat is
the most commonly studied genome uh
given the history of
human domestication of that particular
plant so we know more about wheat than
we know about
cacao and so that's the one that was
selected uh and it's been the genus then
have been inserted into the american
chestnut that's creates this transgenic
chestnut
and then just sort of to show you the
widespread um
oxo gene and so many cultivated foods
here on the right we keep finding more
and more or wild
plants it's and even in fungi and
bacteria the oxo gene is very common uh
and it's a typical de plant defense
mechanism to fungal attack
so uh the way the wheat gene has been
inserted is to piggyback on a naturally
occurring bacteria agrobacterium tomato
so it as you probably know is uh has the
ability to invade the genome of other
species happens quite commonly in nature
and so the wheat gene then piggybacks on
that
so that creates then what we call the
transgenic chestnut which is
99.99 plus percent american it retains
all of the american genes more than 35
000 american chestnut genes plus one
the blight tolerance from lab tests uh
is that it's similar to the blight
tolerance of the chestnut even though as
i mentioned it's a different approach
um but the process begins as a clone so
so much of the work and the work that we
do here at une has been to move through
generations
of breeding to
create genetic and geographical uh
diversification
what's here on the right side of the
screen is uh some of the lab experiments
with the transgenic wheat gene chestnut
uh in the center subjected purposefully
to the
uh inserted fungal blight see what
happens here's the pure american without
the gene which dies within a few weeks
and the chinese when subjected to the
blight also survives and so that's the
kind of lab
results that indicate that inserting the
oxo gene uh works and now what we're
spending a lot of time on is is doing
the field version of the same these same
kinds of experiments so in in cartoon
form here's what happens so the fungal
blight uses oxalic acid to attack
its host and normally that would be that
would kill the american chestnut tree
here which has no natural defense now
with the extra enzyme of oxalic
oxalate oxidase it has a defense
and then the chemical
off products are carbon dioxide and
hydrogen peroxide
uh in in small amounts so it's 35 000
plus genes um that's are retained plus
one um extra gene
and all of this then means it's genetic
engineering of course and that means
that all of our work is subject to
regulatory control and oversight so
everything we do here at une is under a
permit and in particular our
relationship is mainly with the usda who
we
request permits and get permits from but
also uh overseeing our work as epa and
fda who will also need to
judge whether there should be
deregulation we're seeking deregulation
right now
and uh but in the meantime under these
years of permit we've got quite a bit of
work to do
and in particular in the speed breeding
environment where virginia has been so
uh crucial to our advances so i'm going
to turn over the
story to
to virginia right now and tell tell you
guys about our speed breeding project
thank you so much tom that was a great
great introduction so like why are we
doing speed breeding it's mainly because
that um in the wild and orchard uh
chestnuts don't mature until four plus
years to produce pollen so we are
cutting this time immensely and by doing
this we expediate this process by
seedlings to produce indoors round
so you can see some of our success that
we've used two methods which is on the
left which is going to be the transgenic
pollen in the growth chamber versus what
we've grown in the greenhouse so we have
two different methods but because we
have achieved such success with speed
breeding we have become uh the american
chestnut project's leading producer for
the past two years of transgenic pollen
and so you can see in the back that's
tom with one of our seedlings right in
front of the growth chamber
and um just as an example to show how
small the pollen grains actually are
it's only 15 to 20 micrometers which is
which produce which can produce these
like 100 plus foot tall trees which is
amazing
and so our methods that we use
are extended light exposure we use
even temperatures that keep going
throughout the day and night
we have we keep a relative humidity in
both the greenhouse and the growth
chamber
and we use a more acidic water oh that's
the um data that's the ongoing data that
we keep monitoring in our greenhouse
right now so we finally we have access
to it and so we can constantly monitor
it to make sure that our plants are in
peak condition
we also use
we work with the plants and so we work
with what the trees like best and so we
actually reduce the ph of the water
because they like a more acidic soil
we also use
different kinds of fertilizers to keep
up with the like the growth process
and we're still experimenting to see
which pots are best for speed breeding
especially one gallon versus two gallon
which holds the most water and moisture
for the plants versus what makes the
roots grow more or less so we're
constantly experimenting with how we can
make our methods better
and of course
our most most important thing is to keep
uh the pests and pathogens at bay
because that's what really affects the
growing process
so and this um is a kind of temporal
pattern that we have of our pollen
production on the x-axis it's days since
the nut has been like sewn or planted
and then the y-axis is demonstrating how
many slides of pollen have been produced
slides of pollen we're going to talk
about later and what that really means
and so you can see the slow maturation
on the x-axis until about 277 days after
sewing it produces the first pollen and
then you see the exponential pollen
increase and then the roller coaster
pattern comes from the decreases and
then later increases and these are
caused by path and passage pests and
pathogens and the red arrows indicate
like how we can make improvements in
pest mitigation
and so
our decrease in pollen on the last slide
it was caused by these pests and
pathogens which produce a unique
year-round problem so we have to deal
with aphids spider mites mealy bugs
powdery mildew fungus
and fungal gnats
so we use many different methods of pest
mitigation and we constantly have to
monitor our plants like continuously
almost every day for these to make sure
there's no infestations and as you can
see even though how tiny these pests are
they can make a very large impact
so why is it so important to mitigate
pests well we need to keep our
productive like are
producing high yields of pollen for each
seedling so you can see in this one the
pollen is hand collected on microscope
slides like in our graph earlier it was
how many slides of pollen are produced
we use these glass microscope slides to
collect and store pollen
and so after the pollen is collected
four microscope slides can be put into a
labeled plastic vial desiccated to
remove move moisture from the specimen
and then deep freeze at a negative 80
degrees celsius in our special freezers
and so this method our team has produced
has made enough pollen so we can be the
main supplier of the chestnut project
and our research has produced over 850
vials which allows this project to move
forward exponentially quicker than if we
had to rely on regular wild source
pollen
or just regular pollen grown in a lab
you know not sped bread
so
um
this is a total of all our pollen slides
produced at une so each source is
labeled on the y on the x-axis on the
bottom
and then it's pollens it slides that
it's been able to reduce if pollen is
measured on the y-axis and so you can
see that there's a high variability in
the amount of slides that's produced per
source so some of them like
ma317 and wr3o
um are able to
produce like over 50 of all of the
pollen
and while others have not produced any
so this is a high variability that we
have and that's because of the
individual plant genetics
okay and this is a photo another photo
of our process of the desiccation and
freezing process of our pollen and so
our deep freeze allows us to store it
viable pollen and ship it across the
eastern u.s to other branches of the
project
and so this is actually a microscopic
photo of our pollen grains that we were
testing for their viability so you see
the pollen grains and that were able to
fertilize wild flowers that means
they're still viable and when they're
put in this agar solution that mimics um
wild flowers they produce pollen tubes
which show their viability
and so through our research we have been
able to show that frozen pollen is still
viable up to a year for at least a year
and so this is another more microscopic
photos of pollen grains in agar solution
and the photo has been edited to show
the green the grains
that are colored green produce pollen
tubes and are viable while the red ones
did not produce pollen tubes and so they
would not be viable and not fertile
okay so this is a very heavy in-depth
diagram that shows what we call the
chestnut year so from pollination of
wild trees with our lab-grown pollen to
the sowing process to the inevitable
generation of the next new generation of
pollen
so this is a sped up natural process of
the chestnut maturation
we use speed breeding which you can see
is numbers six and seven which is to
produce pollen in record time advancing
our generation of offspring so this is
adding a crucial layer of genetic
diversification like tom was talking
about because it's from a clone so we
need
more generations like out from the clone
to diversify the genetics
and so this is our proof of methods and
how successful we are because this is a
pollen source which is produced pollen
six months from sowing like the actual
planting in the ground well something
like this in the wild would take like up
to normally six years
so where are we now
um
so we're at step five back in the
chestnut year which is the planting and
sewing process so in our greenhouse we
have over we have about 60 diverse
transgenic uh chestnuts that we're
planting and so these will be carefully
monitored and grown in an attempt to
produce the fourth and fifth generations
of crosses that we can use this summer
out in the wild to produce more pollen
so this is what i'm going to be doing
the next couple months i'm very excited
to be working in the greenhouse with
them
so
thanks so much back to tom great great
job virginia uh really nice overview of
the speed breeding process
so now we'll turn briefly to talk about
well what do we do with this um lab
grown
uh pollen on microscope slides that
virginia described so we take it out to
the field
and in the middle of july when the
female flowers on the chestnut trees are
ready for
fertilization we
apply it and that's what's going on in
this picture and we've been doing this
with four wild trees
in in a certain permitted site
in maine over the last couple years to
produce our crosses
so one of the questions we have and one
certainly a really important issue for
usda our regulator is when we're
bringing this pollen to the field that
has the sector gene so it's genetically
engineered does it does it drift pollen
naturally
flies through the air and can go one
kilometer in distance from one tree to
another it's worth noting that chestnuts
are are bisexual but they don't
pollinate themselves so this pollen will
not pollinate this particular flower
even though it's on the same tree uh so
you need two to tango so our what we've
done that is tested whether this pollen
drifts like it does in nature and what
we found is happily zero pollen drift
off of our slides to
two flowers that are not our target uh
that are not inside of our control
pollination bags so that that provides
confidence that our method is very
precise
and confined
so this is what it looks like the fun
part well all this stuff is fun but it's
really fun to go up in the lift and do
our pollination here you see the
pollination bags
uh crossing our pollen with the wild
flowers on these trees
and again the genomics are very
interesting we're learning things um
regularly from genomic analysis that we
didn't know
and what uh it has recently revealed is
that these wild trees that we pollinate
with our a lab-grown pollen actually
have
a significant amount of european species
uh genes anywhere depending on which
tree we're talking about somewhere
between 20 and 50
of their genome comes over from the
european species through
through the importation uh that happened
um many decades ago and the landowners
we work we have no idea how that
happened but that's typical kind of
hybridization that you find once you can
look at it very carefully
uh genomically
the other thing we're doing in the field
is we have these orchards all over maine
and in fact throughout the native range
that other people are responsible for
but the ones we're responsible for in
maine
are typically 100 sampling 100 sampling
orchards that have tremendous genetic
diversity so they're representing the
wild trees throughout throughout new
england as well as other parts
of the native range
and so
we're
doing this sort of genetic and
geographical diversification and so
we're beginning to see some breakthrough
there as these saplings who in this
picture are just four years old or five
years old are beginning to flower and we
can cross them again to
to create um
uh offspring that are flight tolerant
but also represent the native range
so back to this cartoon and the crucial
part of this
picture here is the
the
hydrogen peroxide that is created when
the
fungal blights oxalic acid
meets the oxo gene that's been inserted
in our transgenic chestnut here on the
right this is crucial for our lab
analysis of whether the gene has been
inherited so we do
cotyledon
sample testing in our lab to determine
whether a particular chestnut has the
gene uh it's only on one half of the
chromosome
and so
half of the pollen grains inherit the
gene half of them do not
and so we can do a test then by taking a
sample of the cotyledon which is the
meaty bottom part of the
of the nut
and put it in a reagent that contains
the oxalic acid which is the
the killer uh that's used by the
fungal blight
and we can test whether it has the gene
if it has the gene
it turns the reagents solution black
from the hydrogen peroxide so this
sample here on the left has the gene and
the one on the right
did not inherit the gene this this is
still useful the one on the right
because we do some full sibling analysis
in the field we want to see how the two
perform relative to each other but
that's a really clean uh way very
precise way to find out whether the gene
isn't is inherited and it's very precise
and you know with all the work that you
do at cornell with with reading
this is a really cool thing because we
know exactly who the dad is
because if it has the gene we know
through our our
pollination program and our controlled
pollination bags we know who the debt is
and we know who the debt is on this side
as well because again because of the uh
restricted uh
the inability of wild pollen to reach
inside the bag
so um you might wonder well can we chop
up the nut this way and take a piece out
of the bottom of the nut the cotyledon
tissue and still have a viable nut so
we've tested that over time and we find
that this method of slicing the nut uh
very carefully just a minimal piece does
not affect the
germination so we get germination rates
in our greenhouse
uh that are very similar to what you'd
have a
a chestnut that was not
sampled in this in this method
so here's what our chestnuts that have
the extra gene look like in our
greenhouse this is what we do between
february and may
we grow them indoors
and um we
we try to get them to be basically one
year size equivalent of what they would
be like in the field after one year but
by may we can have them that size thanks
to the greenhouse methods you can see
they're quite happy here's about 400
chestnut
uh seedlings that have inherited the the
transgene here in in one of our
greenhouses and then we've been out
planting them so we have that site you
saw in the video
in cape elizabeth where we have about
500 uh seedlings planted that include
the ones that have inherited the gene
but also their full sibling counterparts
also
is as well in this uh field comparison
we have uh a hundred percent chinese uh
seedlings we have the f1s which are the
50 50 hybrids and we have some that are
advanced hybrids like i showed you in
that poster that have 90 more ballpark
93 american seven percent chinese and
we're going to do we're doing a
controlled
analysis of performance and growth in
the field over over time to see how
indeed the transgenic
approach compares to the the other uh
possibilities so over time then we've
been monitoring them in the field
removing the protective
uh tubes that allowed us to have a kind
of a hardening process in the field and
everything was going hunky-dory in the
field but then
and there are always setbacks we met
virginia talks about the setbacks we
have in long-term breeding indoors with
the pests and pathogens well we got
pests in the field as well so suddenly
out of nowhere seemingly in august of
this year we had a big infestation of
this
what's causing it look at the way that
the
the seedling
stems have been girdled and it turned
out to be mice
that have invaded the orchard so we had
to deal with that uh so there are
various setbacks and that's of course
common in science two steps forward one
step back
um and um
so that's what's happening in the field
it's uh again governed by permit uh
we're seeking deregulation which might
happen within two years and that's going
to be a very different part of the
project when we're allowed to share our
our um light tolerant seedlings with
with others throughout the native range
but in the meantime we've got plenty of
work to do
under permit and so here's what our
orchard looks like in
kind of the most recent stage of growth
you can see
some of our seedlings are are tall some
of them reach four feet tall in the
first year which would be more like a a
two-year-old chestnut growing in the
wild
in full sunlight another interesting
experiment i think is that one of our
seedlings that was a big pollen producer
in the lab we've been able to move out
to the field and and plant and keep
happy as a uh you know as a as a
a seasonal kind of seedling and so we're
hoping that this this particular
seedling which has already had the genes
turned on for pollen production inside
will do the same in the field in short
order in order to provide another source
of pollen uh that would be much easier
for a project to be able to harvest in
field setting so the the goal of then
the field orchard over the next five
years is to compare the relative
performance of the transgenic seedlings
that have the extra gene how do they
hold up how do they grow what's the cost
of having resources devoted to producing
oxalic
oxalate oxidase
uh compared to ones that don't
um how do they withstand the fungal
blight which which is ubiquitous and
eventually we will
subject the seedlings purposefully to
the fungal blight to see how they do
we're also interested in this orchard
becoming a self-reproducing
system of pollen and and female flowers
uh within the transgenic community and
that will eventually then produce
some homozygous transgenics that have
have the gene on both sides of the
chromosome
and so that will be
a great breakthrough
when we get to that stage
and then also just again waiting and
doing what we can in the permit process
to await deregulation so eventually
we're going to have
saplings that are substantial
at the rate they're growing and these
will be then some of the first
saplings that have the gene that have
blight tolerance that we can distribute
by digging them up and moving them to
uh to public publicly
available spots places where the public
can see what we're what we're up to what
they look like
and we begin to the very long-term
multi-decades
process of re-populating the eastern
forest with a tree that that won't die
of the fungal blight
i think we thank you for your attention
and we're interested in the
subsequent discussion and questions so
thank you so much
oh here's moira thank you thank you so
much that was a very uh i loved all the
pictures um i loved the the flyover
of your your orchard nurturing and um
you've done some beautiful work it's
very exciting to see um we've got we're
getting some questions in the chat um
while people are formulating them i have
a couple of questions
um
i wanted to ask if you had to do
anything to get the pollen to stick to
the slide so do you have to put any kind
of like adhesive or treat the sub treat
the slides this pollen is just sticky
enough just to adhere to the slide that
is
it is sticky right it is sticky adheres
quite quite easily yeah there's a
certain method of
sort of tapping the uh
capkin which is where the mal of the
pollen
resides but yeah it sticks really nicely
to the slide
okay my second question is what promoter
was used for the trans gene so
you know promoters can be very tissue
specific but you're you're seeing
expression even in the nut so
um it's probably either under some uh
over regulation or uh ubiquitous uh
promoter yeah it's good question and
that's there's so much so many different
aspects of this project we didn't have a
chance to touch base on but the current
promoter
leaves the
the uh oxalate oxidase on all the time
so it's like a fire hydrant approach
and so that's one of our questions of
whether how much of that matters because
even if the
the plant is not being attacked by
oxalic acid the it's producing and using
resources to produce oxalic
oxalate oxidase to protect itself so
that the the newer version of the
promoter is what's called a wound and
dose induced promoter
and that then is turned on only when
uh it it it
finds the oxalic acid
uh coming its way so that's a more
efficient method that's a newer method
we don't have pollen from that yet we
hope to have that pollen this summer
and then that'll be also an additional
uh important comparison does it matter
we it may not matter it seems like our
uh our on all the time promoter still
grows trees very vigorously not only in
our early experiment but the other work
that's been done
at esf the plants seem to grow quite
quite tall and vigorously under those
conditions but that's certainly
something we're going to uh
look at into the future there that's the
same since it's the same
transgenic
insertion it's governed by the same
permits uh so the the promoter itself is
not something that the usda
has much concerned about it it's the
genetic engineering that yeah okay
excellent
all right so uh we have a couple
questions in the chat one is from bruce
reich um what are the prospects for oxo
resistance being long lasting durable
resistance are there strains of light
that may overcome the resistance
want to make any uh virginia you can
jump in at any point and yeah like um
but let me know if you want me to handle
them um
what do you think i think you can handle
this one like the long lasting but from
what we've seen is the fact that it it
always is producing this and i haven't
seen the resistance it acts similarly
like we said to the resistance that the
chinese chestnut has which is it
co-evolved with it so it's able to kind
of balance it out but tom can probably
talk on the long lasting side yeah
that's yeah that's really important and
the other thing about it's a great
question is that we uh our method does
not kill the fungal blight okay so it's
not um encouraged to mutate in order to
get around it's not a it's not a
pesticide
it's only um
keeping the chestnut tree itself from
being killed but the but we know from
the asian context and even in the
american context because the cryphonetic
parasitica reproduces on oaks it doesn't
kill oaks but it reproduces on them so
it again mentioned before
it it's happy to function as a
saprotroph which basically means it's
consuming dead material um
from other sources so it need not act as
a necrotroph to kill the american
chestnut so we feel that that provides
a long-term
solution
because of the discouragement of
evolving mutating around the around the
defense
okay
uh there's another question from bruce
are there any prospects for nut
production in the greenhouse it is an
impressive gain to obtain pollen in 6 to
12 months but can these trees also set
fruit
yeah i can also talk on this because i
was highly involved in the pollen
production especially last year um so
what we're trying to do is we almost
treat them like tropical plants so
we leave the
larger wild trees to produce like the
female flowers that we use for
pollination in fruit bearing that's not
something that we're able to achieve in
the lab because you need such
like a massive tree because it takes
longer to produce the fruit and the
flowers that come with it so what we've
been focusing on is just the pollen
source which is already hard enough to
do in the lab and we're going to let the
natural process in the wild take that
side of the coin so we're just here to
produce the pollen and it would be
incredible to make
you know nuts in the lab but we're going
to we want to use the natural in wild
genetics to even more diversification in
the future
yeah and it you know those rare
occasions when we do have female flowers
on our seedlings we get all excited
about it they inevitably cannot reach
maturation because there just isn't
enough resources it's a completely
different
ballgame um on the female side so that's
where we rely on the
the um
the either the mature trees or the
saplings in in the field for the female
side of the equation
great
okay another question from jeff doyle
you're propagating chestnuts that are f1
or later generations hybrids between
european sea
sativa and north americans see dentata
and the plan is to repopulate the
eastern us with these trees rather than
with genetically authentic seedentada
does that bother you and what are the
ecological or even bioethical
implications and are there no pure c
dentata that could be used
yeah there are and that's where with
that one slide of the
germplasm conservation orchard
where we're beginning to pollinate those
um
saplings
with our with our transgenic pollen
those are 100
uh pure american
so
um
so we you know there's not just one
outcome there's lots of different types
of crosses in fact we produce 39
different unique crosses this summer uh
between various trees and various on a
variety of different pollens
so we're not relying uh by any means
strictly on the ones that have some
sativa genes the thing about the sativa
which is the european species is that
it's it's the most similar to the
american it also grows as a tall canopy
tree so
phenotypically it's it's
very hard to tell the difference between
the two and that's why we were a little
bit fooled until we had the genomics but
the main tree that we're using in the
field in fact has about 20
uh sativa genes so immediately then when
you do a cross you're down to 10
and then when we're crossing again uh as
we're doing you're down to five percent
european so it's it's a pretty small
percentage uh and remember the other
approach the breeding approach with the
chinese is you're needing
probably at least 10 percent chinese in
order to have and brought likely more
than that more like probably 20 chinese
in order to have enough of the genes
transferred over to provide
light tolerance through the traditional
breeding method
that's a good these are good questions
yeah they're great questions i can kind
of also touch on the bioethical
implications which is
what was it esf did a huge amount of
research with how our transgenic
chestnuts function in the wild
environments and so it actually showed
that they behaved the same way
that the
non-transgenic pure american chestnuts
would so it still had the same effects
it didn't affect pollinators or other
people other organisms that fed on the
leaflet or anything actually tadpoles
grew faster while eating the
transgenic leaf litter or just you know
in general opposed to like if they ate
oak or maple which are the replacement
trees that came in after the
chestnuts were wiped out
another let me add one other thing
because this is a really great question
from from jeff
um
is that and this kind of gets back to
why we have this problem in the first
place with these um
chestnut species being brought into the
united states from other parts of the
world the american chestnut is the
smallest size nut of all the different
options and so
back you know more than 100 years ago
people were bringing these other
chestnuts in because they produce larger
chestnuts or domestic food consumption
so actually one of the advantages of the
of having some sativa genes is that it
produces a larger nut so if so the the
the goal of the restoration certainly is
repopulating the forest but also is to
provide
human food and so a chestnut that has
some
some european genes actually produces a
larger nut which is more valuable uh in
terms of the human
uh
uh
you know consumption side of the demand
so there's going to be a lot of
different demands and certainly if we
were interested in repopulating the
forest for
uh wild animal production where you'd
want a pure american because of smaller
nuts if you wanted for
food production for humans you'd want a
slightly larger nut
jeff did you have another question i see
that you came on your camera so i didn't
know if you had an additional question
you wanted to ask before going on to
tim's question
just wanted people to know i was
actually here
[Laughter]
good to see you good question thank you
very much
okay uh we have a question from tim
setter to virginia your method of
growing plants in the growth chamber is
intriguing please elaborate on what you
mean by saying you use blue light leds
question mark for leaves and red light
for flowers okay so tom has also been
doing a large amount of research on this
and we've had a lot of help with
uh indoor plant growing and how
different kinds of like wavelengths of
light can help
it them grow better so it's like as you
saw some in um our greenhouse photo when
there was about 400 of them there some
of their leaves still had the red spots
on them so that means that they were
still maturing and growing so they could
abso um what is it the blue light is
better for the leaves for them to absorb
it correct me if i'm wrong tom so you
can also talk on this and so the red
light for
flowers you said
induction
yes so um it's that is
for when we were growing them in the
later stages of we used like kind of it
almost looks like a pink light so you go
in and everything's lit up and it's pink
and um it helps promote uh the catkin
growth i'm pretty sure
so which is really cool to see which is
the um produces the pollen so
i'm not exactly sure
the
entirely how it does it but there's
we've learned a lot from other people
that have been doing a lot of like
indoor growing then like
especially the marijuana growers yeah we
have real experts on all of this so we
just
like that
they are the absolute best
uh ones super expensive more because the
price of all this has gone down
dramatically but the uh we would just
put one in our la in our greenhouse that
they say is the
the cadillac as we used to say of of led
lights that has just the right spectrum
to grow your plants
uh most efficiently so that turns
incredible and we're using in one of the
last pictures of our greenhouse now we
have um the heating pads almost to keep
the the chestnuts warm so they're soil
and everything doesn't get too cool and
they can still maintain the right
humidity and temperature
which was another addition from
the marijuana growers they're awesome
[Laughter]
i have another question given the
importance of american chestnut to
indigenous people do you have are you in
doing any kind of
outreach or dei work with any indigenous
tribes um in the area or uh do we know
of anybody who is doing that in the
american chestnut community
yeah great great question really
important question um
because this this tree was important for
literally thousands of years to native
american people
uh so yes there's a lot of conversations
going on
of that sort throughout the native range
with native american people as to what
their interests are their desires are
the certain goal from our side would be
to
provide chestnuts to
any native american people that would be
interested um the big breakthrough on
that it was a a memo of understanding
that was signed about a year ago between
the
american chestnut foundation which we're
part of and the eastern band of the
cherokee indians in um
in the sort of the heart the heart of
the range
and so that was the result of a
long-term conversation which of course
is the appropriate way to go
and
talking about the different interests
and questions that both sides would have
so that that was the big breakthrough
very exciting um but it's certainly
really a priority that any native
american people that would be interested
uh would have access to to trees that um
can survive the fungal blight
especially in maine we're watching uh
actually we were doing genetic testing
and we've been watching and following
the news on different land back
movements especially in maine
in the different uh legal proceedings
that are happening right now
excellent
um any other questions um you're also
anybody who's on the call is welcome to
uh mute themselves or raise their hand i
see lee has a a comment charlie
burnham would be proud of you all thank
you for the seminar
um anybody else have any additional
questions for tom in virginia
and just a quick just so everybody knows
when you hear the word burnham that that
whole plan of of breeding the chestnuts
that we laid out briefly there that was
the burnham plant
uh
tons and tons of decades-long arduous
work
are behind that and really catapulted us
to the point where we are now so yes
thank you charlie burnham
excellent
okay well i wanted to speak up
themselves uh feel free to just chime in
verbally
go ahead moyra didn't mean to interrupt
oh no i'm just
i don't see anybody else with their hand
up i don't see any new chats coming
through so
i'll just be interested in trying to
throw a question back your way nor it or
to anyone else
give us a feel we're out here in uh you
know the northeastern tip of the native
range of chestnuts doing our thing
what did you hear today that connects in
any way shape or form with the kind of
work that's going on in cornell and we
regret obviously with the covid
restrictions we're not right there
rubbing shoulders with you and finding
out about your work but i'd love any
comment from anyone in the audience
about the kind of work you're doing that
has some connection to what we talked
about today
i could certainly go um i'm in i'm
as uh breeding insights working with
several tree species now
uh the promise of genomic selection
and speed burning really opens up a huge
avenue for
improving
you know citrus for hlb tolerance and
maintaining the american
and florida and california citrus groves
um in for in perpetuity or at least
being able to adapt more quickly to
new invasive species um and certainly
pecan would be another one that we would
benefit um but i also see applications
that uh could possibly be used in other
slow growing perennials so something in
more of the shrub and vine
area too that we may be able to um
do some speed breeding for too
and that would really allow us to change
how quickly we can make genetic
improvements in those species rather
than
you know
waiting five years for citrus to flower
making one cross waiting five more years
for the next one to flower we can really
get more
more cycles in much quicker
and so the potential is really big for
me to to
take this technology and try to try to
make it work for other species
anybody else want to comment on uh
the impact that you know anything that
touched them about this marvin
yeah so i have a graduate student
samantha bosco
and she's uh
developing a model for chestnut growth
looking at biomass accumulation carbon
accumulation over time
and also looking at tree establishment
and she's also done a lot of work with
some indigenous communities and some
survey work here in new york with the
senate nation
awesome yeah we'd be very interested in
that we should if you maybe can put us
in touch with samantha that would be
fabulous yep we'll do
yeah good good stuff yeah really
important yeah it's a fast-growing tree
it's a carbon sequestrating each tree
the chestnut is deep taproot so it
survives the wind storms
we've had white pine trees fall on our
big
chestnut trees and break off parts of
them but the chestnut tree
remains standing just kind of showing
the contrast in the
structure of the tree it's pretty
phenomenal
um yeah so good good soil enhancing tree
um and symbiotic
mycorrhizal tree
um i think there's one more question and
there is
that was
uh
was could hydrogen peroxide be a problem
for the transgenic plants
um okay so that's when when we
no i mean hydrogen peroxides are common
in nature
it's all over
um and it's it's you know this is
produced in very tiny amounts uh so it
doesn't really pose any and negative
impact
uh it's yeah we don't see any any
problem whatsoever with with the
production of that as as the oxalic acid
is broken down
uh when the tree is under under attack
anybody else have any questions or
comments they'd like to you know unmute
themselves or turn on their video
okay
well then we'll let you uh tom and
virginia go and have a great uh holiday
season and thank you so much for joining
us and and for uh being able to do this
via zoom um as we mentioned earlier that
we went into red status so all in person
things were cancelled so i'm so glad
that this didn't happen with you on
campus and we still got to have a a nice
uh interaction with you today so thank
you all the best yeah thank you so much
i know you're busy with finals and
everything at the end of the semester
thanks for taking the time out
um to hear hear what we're up to over
here and wish you all the best with the
the covet outbreak
so yeah great thank you it's uh it's
been a pleasure
thank you so much thank you so much
all right bye-bye thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu